il laisse l'image d'un président qui
aimait le contact avec les français la
mort de jacques chirac a donc été
annoncé en fin de matinée il avait 86
ans avant d'entendre ses amis et
adversaires politiques
voyons ce que ces dijonnais rencontrer
tout à l'heure retiennent de son passage
à l'elysée
la dijonnaise et touristes également pas
encore tous au courant dommage pour nous
c'était pas quelqu'un pour lequel
j'avais une grande admiration
je trouve qu'il a bien fait son temps
c'est bien parti tranquille c'est bien
aussi
je trouve qu'ils passaient bien qui
passait bien et il était sympa et que
les gens là-bas notamment pas hésité
contre la guerre en irak donc je pense
que c'était important pour nous bah ça
me touche ce bon je pense que c'était
quand même une grande personnalité il a
eu du mal au début mais il s'est habitué
effectivement au contact salon de
l'agriculture et autres bien sûr il
s'est habitué au contact et il l'a fait
très bien comme les hommes politiques ne
sont plus tellement le faire maintenant
moi j'aimais bien peut-être pas tous
complètement en politique mais dans
l'ensemble je l'aimais bien oui ça m'a
fait de la peine tout ce que j'aimais
beaucoup jacques chirac
et puis mais bon je pense que c'est bien
qu'il soit parti maintenant parce que il
y avait plus grand chose à attendre
je suis triste pour vous il a beaucoup
fait pour la france jacques chirac et la
bourgogne alors bien sûr il n'avait pas
les mêmes attache que son prédécesseur
françois mitterrand
mais les campagnes électorales et ses
déplacements officiels l'ont
régulièrement amenés dans la région
comme le rappelle christophe taris
en termes it here indienne la bourgogne
n'aura pas été pour jacques chirac un
chemin pavé de roses et des pin six ans
quatre présidentielle il n'est arrivé
qu'une seule fois en tête au premier
tour dans la région en 2002 cela ne l'a
pas empêché de battre cette campagne à
la recherche de symboles électorale
comme ici en mars 93 à nevers en pleine
législatives puissent labour de voix
font partie faire chanceler mitterrand
et bérigaud bois dans leur fief
ce qui serait symbolique c'est que des
hommes qui ont conduit la france à la
situation que nous connaissons et qui
ont donc failli à leur mission soit
sanctionné directement pour ce qui
concerne le premier ministre et je
dirais directement pour ce qui concerne
la circonscription de château chinon
mais il a longtemps pu compter sur de
solides appuis dans la région en premier
lieu à dijon avec le maire robert
poujade à montceau avec son ministre
andré jarrot puis dans l'yonne avec un
autre de ses ministres jean-pierre
soisson deux mois avant son accession à
l'elysée jacques chirac paie donc un
passage en bourgogne à la conquête de
voix jacques chirac ne change pas sa
méthode trois heures ici pour parler des
aides aux chômeurs une heure là au coeur
de la bourgogne avec les viticulteurs
dans son duel face à lionel jospin la
région le placera devant avec 51% des
voix
durant ses deux mandats et ses douze ans
de présidence jacques chirac viendra
seulement trois fois en déplacement
officiel dans la région la première en
juin 96 pour un sommet franco-allemand
avec helmut kohl a dit joe large et
sourire du président chirac pour
recevoir son ami helmut kohl qui
l'entraînent dans son exercice favori le
ban foule
en 2002 peu de temps avant sa réélection
il présidera les états généraux de
l'insertion à auxerre puis en 2003 à
nouveau dans l'yonne un voyage autour de
la croissance en allant à la rencontre
de ces acteurs locaux
l'écurie multiple champion du monde oui
surtout rétablir le contact avec les
français
mettre de l'ordre dans l'intendance
hexagonal après les séismes de l'été et
face aux déficits publics ou financement
de la sécurité sociale
jacques chirac choisi de sortir de la
coulisse un jacques chirac à chaque fois
fidèle à son image proche des gens
jamais avare d'une poignée de main se
fait septembre 2003 restera comme sa
dernière venue officielle propos recueil
et pour évoquer la carrière politique de
jacques chirac lilian melet m'a rejoint
et nous retrouvons bonsoir et nous
retrouvons en direct du bureau france 3
d'auxerre jean-pierre soisson ministres
des différents gouvernements chirac
jean-pierre soisson jacques chirac était
pour vous plus qu'un allié politique un
véritable ami while tout à pomas ma
carrière politique
ce soir nous avons suivi le même
parcours de formation sciences po l'ena
la cour des comptes
l'algérie et puis j'ai appartenu
effectivement 74 à la fin 76 à tous et à
tous ces gouvernements
j'entendis ce matin tous les
commentaires sur jacques chirac et je
veux non ce que je pourrais vous dire le
le nouveau quand le plan personnel dire
que vous avez été giscardien vous au
départ et que c'était pas être
chiraquien être jusqu'à revient non
vetere au départ on sait au chap
fâché l'un contre l'autre même et même à
l'elysée quand il a créé le rpr ça c'est
vrai mais il avait une façon de vous
dire les choses qui étaient tout à fait
tout à fait creuser une minute tu dis
des conneries et plus grandes sont les
mêmes et à table il était merveilleux il
aimait la tête de veau j'aime la tête de
bruxelles et loire mort j'ai la tête de
veau vous avez rappelé et c'est venu à
auxerre
quand il est vu par des insertions ça
incroyable le délégué départemental du
rpr vous propose s'appelait à l'époque
avaient préparé de corona mois une
bouteille de coulanges et enfiler de
corinna l'admettait la bouteille de
boulanger pierre commence il partait
pour visiter les viticulteurs abonnés y
tenait un meeting politique qu'elle
emprunte pour vous laisse jacques chirac
c'est une empreinte intérieur avec sa
popularité à la fin de sa carrière ou
une empreinte internationale aussi on se
souvient d'un certain nombre de prises
de position de la deuxième guerre du
golfe en particulier
écoutez moi j'ai ça à soutenir la dame
des landes très proche
et de réformes sur le plan intérieur la
suppression du service militaire prévôté
tessin bien s à mal que tous les
français passent ensemble à la caserne
je trouvais ça bien et la grande réforme
c'est quand même l'opposition aux états
unis lors de la guerre la guerre d'irak
la france parlé haut et clair et à
l'entendre nous avons tous étaient fiers
merci jean pierre soisson puis auxerre
jacques chirac souvent caricaturé pour
son côté family lors de ses déplacements
quarante ans de carrière politique qui à
peu près autant de visite au salon de
l'agriculture à paris
les éleveurs se souviennent de sa
défense de la politique agricole commune
réactions recueillies par à mes dix
doigts et romain me pose chaque année la
star incontestée du salon de
l'agriculture c'était lui une tête au
dessus de tout le monde
il ne manquait jamais d'aller flatter la
croupe des vaches presque aussi à l'aise
que les éleveurs eux-mêmes
selon charles aubry qui a eu de nombreux
soit l'occasion de serrer la main du
président on le sortait deux trois
années où les plus ventées et flatté sur
la tête l'avait quant au point pas du
tout je pense que ce petit génie du
collège des vaches sont inquiets le
petit coup convivial et bon vivant
c'est aussi comme cela que pierre s'en
souvient le salon il en arpenté chaque
allée et en 1999 à l'époque de la
cohabitation
il a même réussi à semer son ministre de
l'agriculture de l'époque jean glavany
et j'en bois il s'exécutait pas ce qu'il
peut pas dire non et puis il essayait de
suite mais il ya eu un moment il a fallu
sortir du défilé passe crient ils
pouvaient plus suivre chirac il avait
ratatiné mais ça fait partie des grands
soumis aux femmes
mais si l'homme restera dans le coeur
des agriculteurs c'est surtout parce
qu'ils les comprenez et que ce fut selon
le bien le seul penseur comme tous les
ruraux
on est en deuil la ruralité il a surtout
fait warcq le pouvoir l'état étaient
derrière sont allés tous tuerie il
savait très bien que l'agriculture était
et est toujours même si elle est
incomprise est toujours une des grandes
valeurs de la france jacques chirac a
arpenté 40 ans le salon il n'a manqué
qu'une seule édition à cause d'un grave
accident de voiture et complicité dans
sa longue carrière jean jacques chirac a
croisé la route de nombreux élus de
notre région lilian melet vous allez
justement vu rencontre raconté à ces
rencontres
oui en commençant par christian paul à
l'époque il est député socialiste de la
nièvre et il entre au gouvernement avec
le portefeuille d outre-mer on est en
2000 jacques chirac a dissous
l'assemblée en 97
lionel jospin entre les ministres c'est
la cohabitation et christian paul
s'assoie à la table pour la première
fois du conseil des ministres on écoute
pour les jeunes générations jeunes
chirac c'était un formidable combattant
politique c'était aussi un adversaire
et quand je suis rentré bout d'un manche
entraînant son gouvernement de la
république
j'ai eu en effet avec lui des rapports
républicain il avait appris chemin
faisant l'utiliser quand même d'un
gaullisme très très combatif et d'une
droite dure vous l'avez dit il avait
sans doute appris à comprendre le pays
peut-être que l'exercice d'ailleurs la
présidence de la république a aidé à
mieux comprendre le c'était choquant
c'est utile dans l'exercice de sa
fonction
autre témoin françois patriat l'ancien
président de la région bourgogne et il
connaît son chirac françois patriat
d'abord il limite très bien souvent et
s'en sert prier faut le dire et puis
surtout depuis son entrée à l'assemblée
en 1983 françois patriat a souvent
croisé la route de jacques chirac il a
surtout fréquenté lui aussi dans les
années 2000 sous le gouvernement jospin
et admiraient sa capacité sa bonhomie à
convaincre son émerveillement sur les
choix du monde son côté culturel il
avait un côté lui une passion pour les
arts premiers
dans le même temps
les français ont le sentiment qu'il
était proche d'eux et qu'ils étaient il
va côté paternaliste et puis il ya la
droite avec là aussi beaucoup de
sourires
oui dans une région très marquée on l'a
dit tout à l'heure par l'empreinte
mitterrandienne jacques chirac a tout de
même posé sa patte en quelques clichés
on va d'abord cité robert poujade ancien
maire de dijon
il a été plusieurs fois ministre en même
temps que jacques chirac à cette
occasion il a d'ailleurs été le premier
ministre de l'environnement français et
il a eu des fonctions importantes ali dr
puis au rpr les parties jacques chirac
autre portrait simone rignault décédé en
janvier dernier en 93 elle part à
l'assaut de la circonscription du morvan
celle de françois mitterrand elle
devient un symbole de la reconquête rpr
jacques chirac vient la soutenir à 2,6
entre les deux tours vous l'avez vu tout
à l'heure dans les images de la rétro et
elles l'emportent si mourinho et elle
aimait raconter qu'à paris jacques
chirac l'avait prise par le cou et l'a
présenté à tout le monde en disant vous
vous rendez compte elle a gagné la
circonscription de mitterrand et puis
autre femme de droite et ne sont pas
très nombreuses dans cette génération
marie louise fort l'actuel maire de sens
ancien député une chiraquienne
chimiquement pur qui va même intégré
l'équipe de campagne du candidat chirac
en 2002 elle fait partie des députés
symbole mise en avant dans les meetings
chargé de chauffer la salle pour le
patron au fil des années elle a noué
aussi une relation étroite avec
bernadette chirac ont l'écoutent c'était
cet après-midi ce que j'ai toujours
apprécié c'est que je n'étais pas là
grand déluge
du pays mais il a toujours su écouter et
puis ne pas prendre à la légère les
relations qui pouvait avoir avec qui
compte c'était quelqu'un qui était non
seulement très proche des gens mais
vraisemblablement de leurs
préoccupations
donc voilà c'est une page d'histoire de
france qui se tourne et je suis triste
mais je sais aussi que bon ça fait
partie
on va dire de la vie comme m'a dit une
de mes concitoyennes ce matin merci les
lions et nous viendrons bien sûr sur la
mort de jacques chirac dans l'édition
nationale tout à l'heure à 19h30 notons
qu'une journée de deuil national est
prévue ce lundi en france